what's up everybody welcome to forza
horizon 3 i'm dave Jewett joined today
by tomorrow is st. and Lucy James you
want to say hello guys nope hello guys
hello guys so we're all gonna meet up
and then do a race across Australia or
at least the part of Australia that that
exists in in Forza horizon three you
guys want to make your way over to our
little waypoint so i can get this race
going all right hmm i do have some
issues with the Australia in Forza
horizon three it's quite accurate right
yeah I mean like just places have been
cut out and just dropped in complete
wrong area of the country it seems is
this you I can see coming up Lucy it is
so we should preface this we with we've
not actually seen any like each of those
cars we've all spent time designing it
and made our own little custom
automobile she'll just you're just looks
like a like a word art affect mine yeah
it's like bang in the dirt is gone
sylhet bang Tilly banker and well what
do you think of mine uh oh let me have
it so say was I say hunk for a ramp oh
my god hung for Iran bay I am taken to
say hmm you like my number plate as well
what is it custom I can't just dank meme
oh for God's sake wine says in inmate 2
in may to which is arrested
right frightening moment cuz it wouldn't
let me have a new start you guys ready I
can see some headlights on the horizon
we started this race the right time as
well sun's just coming up beautiful look
at those hot air balloons cats oh yeah
I'm telling them to me where you at is
that this fast as your car goes Jesus
Christ I'm gonna cough buggy haha have
you got a hood Mini Cooper over there oh
hang on some pink is pink no go that's
very pink behold look at this beauty oh
you could hear it coming from miles away
as well uh hang on I just wanted to
point out all the details right there we
have scheana aki on the side if you look
closely there she's I'll show you the
front your number place has text me text
me yet what does the Japanese say God
knows look at this she's having boobs of
rest hey sorry I'm good what's going on
look maybe her runaway car I was trying
tell unbelievable right everyone line up
so i get this race is good oh wow can
you hit my place so what we're doing
today is gonna miss his wife room in
this car top left corner of the map
we're gonna go all the way down to the
broken agave yep I'm you don't know
where we're going go into the byron bay
lighthouse first one there wins last one
there has to clean out Tam's car oh
right that one night it's a lot of body
pillows in her mommy's oh my god I gotta
go spin I gotta spin you ready wait oh
that's the stupid gambling before forza
horizon three locom sweet got new car
okay did come up in my dick justice a
shared is everybody ready yeah it's got
a four by four sheep since my fro play
all right on three two one hey you went
before 11 before one lucie de Vlasic
shapes
yeah classic in cjs I was wheel spinning
I didn't take my nose done only one art
oh no i'll go there's a tree here I've
tried to oh I see we've all tried to do
the off-road into it just on real bad
real fast haha it's only these cars were
like the horse in the new Zelda okay I'm
park gorilla yeah the wildlands is my
domain I'm Annie made I ran away hey
guys anywhere near me I'm doing rich
people that write a long way I've over
shocked I'm in my natural habitat now
that's right much that's the cars
natural habitat not her ambos okay
i leveled up there's a bear on the left
bears oh no sorry she said bear left
what so one of the things I'll be
interested to see if they have in here
in Australia on the cuz obviously it's a
big big country there's a lot of driving
to get from one place to another you can
they have these big attractions on like
the side of the road so they can have
like a big sheet which is just a massive
machine but my favorite one is the the
big banana alright this is a giant
bonanno you can't go to action what's
going on oh yeah tom was trying to say
that there are no kangaroos ins I had
not seen them and if I haven't seen him
they don't exist wait so you mean you
don't believe in wind no wind is it
alive anime is I believe in the tent
rails oh my god oh my god help me with a
little pink pocket rocket just zoom past
me boom on self us to Mars car or like a
vibrator could be both you don't know
it's in that car hey why are you dipping
around the entire road this is the
listen hacking going on here you said I
like to engine again your car is doing
exactly the same Emma guy so he just
maybe lag switching toys are be honest I
just think that's our internet cuz I had
a hell of a time trying to even a login
to xbox live Sam get the hell away from
me don't touch my car with Yahoo phase
the way from fee you're all over the
shop that's how animated works this is
your Howard power you're not even fast
and furious they have nos in there cause
I have a waifu in my passenger seat is
that body pillow powering every now and
then she goes yeah I can see time
harnessing the power of the great
gorilla so who its gorilla vs. anime
versus Lucy silly bang mobile
yeah iris tomorrow sorry I needed to
speed up the door those around me making
such a song for him well what I guess
anyways my own even level is over 9000
tam you you're brave grant into that
corner it's a China knife am the lord
have nothing what's going on here I'm so
close behind you going here huh no sir
no you're in the jungle baby this is
where gorillas live enemy waifu let's do
this what's her name again she knows
it's your wife Lou Janaki she's one of
many i got side damn you are zipping
around also by haha hey this King quick
eject all there's a cuanto action
figures maybe you lose some weight and
be else goes body pillows and weighed
down by body pillows Ella's on that
heavy sunlight by nature know if they're
filled with something my guy boys your
airbag situation that car is it like
when I was gonna make mouse cursor she's
got two airbags what have u Bochy
crashing behind me Oh fine thank you for
asking it's Phillips camera you're well
be this game is bloody gorgeous by the
way stop boy haha you know what you
deserve that cuz you rammed me oh god I
think I just killed a family of five
what I smashed a person two people
carrier teen scene oh alright let's just
carry on this way just nine
something about why is there no
shortcuts cuz it's not my real car was
at burswood heads oh we got a green
shiny damn uh shroom I mean I'm looking
for giant sheep and bananas to hang out
with you guys mess around back there
guys don't worry when we finish here i'm
gonna show you my 500 pics just picture
strong uh australia 2011 I'm afraid I
got to go home with you this so no I
just please god no thank God I believe
in what I can't you again god save me ah
hold on Johnny you guys chance the
Rattlers grandpa is he a rapper I don't
know he is a rapper yes he is a rapper a
little bit ago oh god I see Lucy my my
rearview mirror not today James good you
mean oh god what I just went through
someone's bins yeah they're not gonna
get post for a week after you went
through their garden my favorite thing
about when you go through been during an
XP food boost called trash man Dave stop
trying to ram oh you just bounced off of
silver target i was playing peggle i was
about to mock you for crashing into
someone's car and then i'm nearly just
full on what destroyed another family
back in the dirt road oh my
four-by-fours time to shine Oh spin for
prize um how much gambling has to wait
new see it's got your addictions getting
sick I flew over my crisis no you're
right I'm sorry I don't follow just
stopped off at the front there for a
quick spin on the ferris wheel go away
Dave go away victory o yours yes what
why are you on my screen I challenge you
to a race the trine distraction it
didn't work no it didn't work at all
scream Oh
oh so close victorious I suppose it to
the tune of Moses Emily Ryan dresses
join cheating hacks you using what skill
uh story of my life you okay tell me
you're alive I alright guys it's there
and back oh [ __ ] if that way point
nothing no you gotta memorize the road
are we going hey we're just gonna play
forza horizon for us today i think so
much hey I hope you guys are home
enjoyed watching and if you did make
sure you hit that like button subscribe
to gamespot and shower DC James 44 hacks
I mean we'll see you next time bye bye